when we try to inform our
decision-making processes frequently we
defer judgment and defer the decision
moment saying we need more information
we can't make that decision and yet
there's a cognitive link between where
that moment fires in our brain that is
the emotional part of the brain that
actually lights up and so this for me
was really it was a profound element and
I'm sure it's an element in all of our
work because we find ourselves very
emotionally committed to many of the
things that we do when we practice
research and yet in order to function as
a researcher and engage the analytical
part of our brain we need to shut that
emotion off frequently so then how do we
then re-engage the emotional parts and
the communication ability effectively
the entire part of our brain system in
order to be able to effectively
communicate to those people that need to
effectively inform taking information
but also register it find whether or not
its resonant with personal value be able
to engage the emotional part of the
brain and then make a decision that's a
very complex process and it's something
that we're learning an awful lot about
these estimates of the values of
ecosystem services ran counter to a lot
of the mindsets of the way people
believe that value should be assigned
and putting a number on something or
making something visible was very much
like holding a lightning rod and from a
number of different perspectives this
was either unacceptable or began to not
reflect the the ways in which many
people thought about systems it was
especially challenging because total
economic value was generally assigned to
those elements on the far left-hand side
of the diagram the direct use benefits
the tangible elements of ecosystems and
ecological services often times were on
the in the mid part of the diagram where
they were somewhat less tangible they
were less rival they were less
excludable therefore they were less more
credible and then that didn't even begin
to encompass all of these values on the
far right-hand side the most intangible
values those that had were about option
value the quest value or existence value
and this is particularly important for
our agencies when we are thinking about
how we make decisions because as Pavan
just mentioned at the beginning and as
rich covered talking about the discount
rate a dollar in the present day is not
either cognitively or realistically the
same as a dollar in the future however
our natural capital is just as relevant
if not more to the population today as
it will be in the future so as a result
we need to be treating our decision
processes on different timeframes and
frequently public agencies have things
like annual budgets you get your your
allocation from Congress you have one
year to spend it if you don't spend it
with in that calendar year you probably
lose it if you spend it in such a way
that that it saves things like energy or
say you pay money for recycling
frequently money goes back to the
Treasury as a whole and we don't have
those feedback systems that are bringing
incentive back to those decision-makers
so that they can keep the savings for
themselves thus they're not they're
making the best decisions for individual
units but with respect to the entire
system over time we're seeing the same
processes of overdraft occurring so what
that means is we need to be correcting
feedback loops in who is getting the
incentive and when they're getting it we
also need to think about time horizons
imagine for example if you're going to
decide should I rent an apartment this
year or should I take the leap and buy a
house this year the first year you make
that decision you are down in the red
and if everyone were making their all of
their decisions and this is currently
how we're making our decisions about
natural capital we don't want to make
the decision to buy that house in
rest in that infrastructure or build up
our stocks because in the immediate term
and emotionally we are seeing that as
being in the red without the ability to
see the long term and the systemic
perspective and also emotionally and
cognitively calculate and anticipate
that breakeven date right where the gray
turns to red here
you